for next year and this is actually going
to creep up on you really really fast
okay you'll need to make a decision
midway through this we're about what
Matt's are going to in year 11 okay now
I just have a quick question for you
raise your hand if you have any idea one
v 1 v 2 v 3 means anyone
yeah okay that's right do you guys know
what levels you do and you told that or
you general Tom you talked okay that's
right my point is simply I would refer
this later on it will really help you to
know roughly what level you're at
they're not they're not sort of clear
cuts divisions usually we say v 1 v 2
and v 2 v 3 and everyone's sort of it's
a spectrum but I'm gonna refer that
later on so if you don't know which one
you're basically in you should find out
when you go into school okay now here's
the important thing that I wanna get
across to you you have these choices for
next year right in you're 11
you could either do no maths at all okay
you can choose them in your maths thank
god I've been waiting 10 years to do
this okay or you get to choose between
these three levels of maths okay now
hands up if you've seen these
alternatives before you see it you've
heard of general and to unit m3 inner
hand straight up okay could keep your
hand off if you think you know anything
about what the difference is between
them are just keep getting up okay all
right let's see I would just want to see
what you know okay
what would you say what's the difference
that the general may see yep
okay so that's the first thing it is
correct so generally speaking I've sort
of arranged it in terms of difficulty
very generous minion okay so you are
getting hired as you going down are
there any other things we know about
what's different between takers yeah
good yeah okay so when you're going
between these one of the things that
makes them more difficult is that the
topics from here to here and here to
here actually different and there are
harder topics in these kinds of areas
and I could name them for you if we have
the time now is there anything else we
know about the differences between them
anything okay right I'm gonna give you
I'm gonna introduce a big word to you
okay
it's really important because um the sad
thing is the biggest difference between
these three courses is no one's known
said it yet and I suppose it because no
one's told you so but what if any of you
have heard of the word
almost has anyone seen this word before
ever
yeah okay do you think you know it means
I'm just gonna scratch my head okay I
first heard about this when I was
reading tinting books because there was
professor calculus
anyway I'll show mage now calculus is a
big topic okay in fact it's not just a
big topic it's a it's an overarching
kind of theme and there are all these
subtopics underneath them okay
things like limits and differentiation
integration 16 or 17 of these subtopics
that go underneath it okay you can go to
the board of studies that link I showed
you before and actually look up the
scissor stock events and find out what
these up here's the thing you need to
get look at these three okay
general maths - unit and three unit
that's what this one could really call
okay the difference between them is
calculus right in fact two unit and
three inner are really their actual
names are they called the calculus
courses general mass is just a shorthand
way of saying mass without calculus okay
now what is calculus I can't give you a
full explanation the whole idea but the
the important thing you need to get is
that to do calculus well and to
understand what's going on to be very
strong with the algebra very strong with
your trigonometry and here's is the
kajabi
and if I come back to this for a second
right the difference is you go down is
not just difficulty and it's not just
this topic but it's what we call
abstraction abstraction now what that
means is abstract problems are the
opposite of concrete problems so
concrete problems are Johnny has for you
know Snickers bars in this hand and five
Mars bars in this hand what does Johnny
have
you know probably diabetes is then what
he done he has but you know that's
that's the concrete sort of problem
right as you further down you go away
from concrete problems and you go
towards weird abstract imaginary ideas
like okay if I could give you a series
of numbers that go on forever that go on
forever can you say that's equal to
something and the x-rays you can by the
way this is evens one okay but how does
that work or what happens when you take
numbers and you end up with zero divided
by zero or infinity divided by infinity
what do those even mean now can you see
what I mean by these are not concrete
problems they're not like you know
people math teachers they make up things
there I go imagine a frog that jumps
halfway across the room and then a
quarter the rail cross women they make
those stories up there I do them but
that's ridiculous there are no frogs
that do such a thing
right this problem is completely
invented okay then abstract problems so
your algebra and your trigonometry and
your ability to imagine there what you
mean is you go further down this list
okay in fact I frequently I'll get onto
the next page in my year to our class
which is for UMass Extension - I
constantly have to say now imagine this
with me that's the phrase that starts
off a lot of my lessons okay so if you
have trouble holding imagining
mathematical concepts in your head that
lends you to order some of these courses
up here they'll be much more appropriate
to you okay now ah let's see where am i
up to oh right how do you decide how do
you decide where I fit okay so I'm still
under you know choosing your theater
okay
let me give you four questions that you
should ask yourself okay four questions
you should ask yourself the first
question I've already been talking about
which is ability okay do you think you
know go have a look at your previous
tests have a look at how you what stream
you're in and however before you do you
think you have the ability for these
harder courses that's the first thing
you need to ask okay and if you don't if
you're listening you know doing these
harder courses will not benefit you if
the whole time you're just gonna be
struggling it will affect your other
courses I'll get off that later okay the
second question is do you have any
desire or interest in these things
okay now you can be very good at
something but not be interested in it
okay that won't usually sort of motivic
all the way through a two-year course
okay so there's the second question the
third question is will you at any stage
be using that in the future okay no I
can tell you one of the things that the
general math course is it's really
really practical okay so for instance I
can tell you right now there are two
focused studies in it one's about move
off own plans and the other one is about
driving and costs associated with that
so it's a super practical course okay as
you go further because you're not
getting concrete problems you're getting
abstract ones right they become
different they become more interesting
people who are maybe going towards
science or engineering or even commerce
okay if you study Commerce you got
quantitative methods of accounting and
you'll need that kind of thing the last
question is your other subjects okay now
the reason why I mentioned that is you
might have said yes it's all three of
these questions right new medicine yeah
I've got the ability right yes I want to
yes I think I'm gonna use in the future
but you really need to keep this in the
context of all the other units you're
gonna be studying this you know okay let
me give you a prime example I have tons
of students who are desperate to do
extension once - okay either they are or
their parents are desperate for them to
do it okay for whatever reason okay and
they come to me and they say sir I'm put
you know this number of hours in
every night I would really good it's
gonna be great okay and then I always
ask them well okay how much time you're
going to spend on the other subjects you
can study okay
prime example not just because the
English teachers in the room is English
right
English is special in the interesting
you must absolutely no matter how bad
you are at English count two years of
your English studying in the interesting
okay doesn't matter if you crash
inverted ESL you still okay so if you're
putting all of your hours into all this
right here and you're letting your other
subjects suffer there's kind of no point
okay I know the students who've gone
99.95 okay they're always well balanced
students okay when I teach them they're
always distributing their time very
carefully and being balanced about it
okay so these are the four questions you
can't ask for yourself and only you can
answer